مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في موجز الانباء نقلت
وكاله تاس عن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها صدت هجوما اوكرانيا في 5 قطاعات في
اتجاه جنوب دونيتسك كما نقلت راوترز عن
الوزاره ان القوات الروسيه احبطت هجوما
اوكرانيا واسعا نطاق في جنوبيه اوكرانيا
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط محاوله
تسلل جديده من قبل من سمتها مجموعه
تخريبيه اوكرانيه لعبور الحدود في مقاطعه
بيجرود الحدوديه لكن حاكم المقاطعه اعرب
عن استعداده لمقابله مسلحين الذين اعلنوا
عن اسر جنديين روسيين في منطقه شيبكيني
لبحث عمليه مبادلتهم
من جهته قال مستشار رئاسه الاوكرانيه
ميخائيل انه يجب اعتبار الاحداث في شبهينو
على انها مستقبل روسيا اضاف انه باستخدام
بلده صغيره كمثال فانهم يشهدون نهايه عصر
استقرار بوتين حسب تعبيره
افاد مراسل الجزيره في الخرطوم انا طائرات
حربيه تابعه للجيش السوداني استهدف
التجمعات لقوات دعم السريع في منطقه
الجريف شرقيه الخرطوم والتصاعدت اعمده
الدخان عقب القصف الذي استهدف مزرعه مطله
على النيل ويحدى المدارس المستخدمه من قبل
الدعم السريع كمعسكر لقواته
الجيش السوداني للجزيره ان قوات استعاده
السيطره على قاعده النجوم الجويه في جبل
اولياء جنوب الخرطوم اشار مصدره في الجيش
السوداني لان القاعده كانت تحت سيطره قوات
الدعم السريع منذ بدايه الاحداث وتم
استعادتها بعد معارك وسطها بالعنيفه داخل
القاعده الجويه
دعت المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع الى التوصل الى اتفاق جديد على وقف
اطلاق النار وتنفيذه بشكل فعال بهدف بناء
وقف دائم للعمليه العسكريه وقال بيان
لوزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان الرياض وواشه
حريصتان على استمرار المحادثات مع وفدي
التفاوض السودانيين
قالت القياده الامريكيه في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ ان السفينه الحربيه
الصينيه قامت بما وصفته بالمناوره غير
الامنه قرب مدمره امريكيه في مضيق تايوان
يوم السبت واوضحت القياده ان السفينه
الصينيه اقتربت من المدمره الامريكيه حتى
صارت على بعد 140 مترا منها فقط وما اجبر
طاقم المدمره الامريكيه على تخفيف السرعه
لتفادي الاصطدام
وقد حذر وزير الدفاع الصيني من اقامه
تحالفات عسكريه شبيهه بحلف الناتو في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ قائلا انها
ستغرق المنطقه في دوامه من الصراعات بشان
توحيد الصين امر حتمي واذا بجين لن تتسامح
مع اي محاولات لفصل
في هذه الاثناء وصل مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه لشؤون شرقي اسيا والمحيط الهادي
الى بجين وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
المسؤول سيناقش القضايا الرئيسيه في
العلاقات الثنائيه ومنها قضايا حقوق
الانسان والحريه
على وقع توتر متصاعد في البلقان عبر
الامير العام للنيتو عن ترحيبه بارسال
تركيا جنودا اضافيين الى كوسوفو لدعم
الاستقلال والامن هناك اضاف ان الحلفه صاد
ذي ارسال نحو 700 جندي اضافيا الى هناك
مؤكدا ان تركيا تقود جهود تامين تلك
القوات
وقد اتهم قائد القوات الدوليه لحفظ السلام
رئيس حكومه كوسوفو البينكورتي باتخاذ
اجراءات احاديه الجانب اجججت الاوضاع وقال
ان رئيس وزراء كوسوفو ارسل رؤساء البلديات
الجدد الى منشات البلديه دون مراعاه نصيحه
المجتمع الدوري بين الشرطه استخدمت القوه
دون استشاره قوات النيتو ودعا الى بدء
مفاوضات حقيقيه بين صربيا
انتهى المجزا في امان الله
[موسيقى]